PlayStation 5 is still on its way for
this holiday Unreal Engine 5 is actually
pretty real and the Mafia trilogy is
getting a remaster I'm Curt and you've
made it to your save state for May 13th
bust out the pita because it's
international hummus day calm those
little hearts of years because nothing's
standing in the way of this next
generation of video games the
PlayStation 5 is still coming this
holiday season Sony stated in an
earnings report that kovat 19 has not
affected its launch plans saying quote
regarding the launch of PlayStation 5
although factors such as employees
working from home and restrictions on
international travel have presented some
challenges in regards to part of the
testing process and the qualification of
production lines development is
progressing with the launch of the
console scheduled for the 2020 holiday
season end quote a specific launch date
hasn't been confirmed yet neither has a
price are you gonna pick up PS 5 this
holiday season or are you just gonna set
it right back now Unreal Engine 5 is
actually looking pretty damn real based
on a tech demo that was released today
what we saw was real-time gameplay
created using Unreal Engine 5 running on
the PlayStation 5 the new engine has two
core technologies nanite and lumen mana
is a virtualized geometry system that
allows artists to import billions of
pixels directly into their game lumen is
a dynamic lighting system that can
realistically light an environment
without having to bake in light sources
basically games are about to get a whole
lot prettier and developers should have
an easier time making them so ue 5 will
be released in 2021 and if there's
anything learned from the demo is that
games are gonna have a lot more
triangles best demonstrated with this
image thank you to more hussain for
clearing that up for more detailed
breakdown on ue 5 stay tuned here at
GameSpot and of course you can't talk
about unreal and epic without talking
about fortnight which is coming as a
launch title to the PlayStation 5 and
Xbox Series X the version that will be
available on those consoles will be
running
Unreal Engine 4 however epic has said
fortnight will be ported over to Unreal
Engine 5 in the middle of 2021
personally I think it'd be sweet to
launch it with another in-game concert
with like Cisco or Michael Bolton or
both of them who do you want to see
before I'm next in fortnight and why is
it Michael Bolton in Cisco the Mafia
Twitter account sure whacked us with a
surprise the mafia trilogy is getting
remastered 2k games released a teaser
trailer saying mafia 1 2 & 3 are coming
to ps4 Xbox one and PC a full reveal is
coming on May 19th the Microsoft Store
meanwhile published screenshots of the
first mafia which looks to have been
given the full remake treatment the
store also lists an August release date
for the game finally I can relive my
truest roots I also hope that the
collector's edition comes with a pair of
cement boots anyways come back here then
wait for more info those were just a few
of the big stories that happen today but
of course there's those and a whole
bunch of other ones you can read about
at gamespot.com I'm Kurt feel free to
say hello to me whenever you want on
twitter at curt underscore in davina and
make sure to come back for tomorrow's
safe state with persia wash your hands
and tell someone you love them see ya
[Music]